Have you ever found yourself
just utterly bewildered by how
two people can look at the exact
same event, the same footage,
even the same person, and, well,
come away with completely
opposite interpretations?
You know, where one sees a hero,
the other sees a villain.
Absolutely.
It happens all the time.
It's a phenomenon that really
cuts right to the heart of how
we understand conflict, history
and frankly, the very fabric of
our societies.
So today we're embarking on a
deep dive into the profound
truth behind that.
That age-old phrase, one man's
freedom fighter is another man's
terrorist, right?
We're going to explore why this
isn't just, you know, a simple
cliche, but actually a
fundamental reality that deeply
shapes how we perceive the world
around us.
And what's truly fascinating
about this concept, I think, is
how deeply ingrained it is.
It's in human nature.
It's woven through historical
narratives.
I mean from ancient rebellions
right up to modern day
movements, societies have
consistently grappled with this
this dichotomy.
One group elevate certain
figures, as you know, noble
rebels, champions of Liberal the
hero, while another group
condemns those exact same people
as dangerous villains, threats
to stability.
And the distinction, as we'll
get into today, it often hinges
entirely on perspective.
Perspect, yeah.
Whose narrative you believe,
whose side you're on, maybe what
meaning you choose to assign to
their actions.
It's a really powerful and often
subconscious mechanism of
societal interpretation.
And our sources, they take this
concept even further.
They introduce this really
compelling framework, they call
it Dimension A and Dimension B.
Now, these aren't physical
places you can visit, obviously,
not even distinct geographical
regions.
Instead, you should think of
them as two entirely separate
mental frameworks, almost like 2
distinct realities that, well, a
significant portion of Americans
currently inhabit
simultaneously.
Sounds a bit.
Sci-fi, but it's a useful way to
think about.
It it is, Yeah.
It's almost like living in
parallel universes, you know,
sharing the same physical space
but perceiving it through
fundamentally different lenses.
That's precisely the idea.
So in dimension a defiance, and
that could be almost any act of
opposition or non compliance
against established authority.
It gets interpreted as noble
resistance, a brave, necessary
stand against what's perceived
as injustice or oppression.
OK, so defiance equals
resistance in.
A Pretty much.
But then, on the flip side,
Dimension B views that exact
same defiance, those identical
actions, as dangerous chaos, an
unacceptable threat to order,
stability, the rule of law.
Wow.
OK, polar opposites.
Exactly.
And what's crucial to
understand, I think, is that
these dimensions don't typically
engage in direct debate.
They don't often seek to
understand each other's
viewpoint.
Right, they just sort of
coexist.
They largely coexist as separate
realities, only occasionally
clashing.
And when they do collide, it's
often through these high impact
events, A viral video that just
sweeps the Internet.
We see those all the.
Time a social media storm that
ignites a national conversation.
Or, you know, unfortunately,
real life conflicts that force
these divergent interpretations
into direct, often explosive and
profoundly irreconcilable
collision.
OK, so our mission for this deep
dive is pretty clear.
Then we aim to navigate these
complex, often colliding
realities.
We're going to sift through the
provided sources, try to extract
the most important Nuggets of
knowledge, the key insights to
help you, our listener, really
understand what defines these
two Americas.
And maybe even more critically,
we'll explore the profound
implications of their collision.
We'll delve into how these
vastly different perceptions are
formed, what happens when they
inevitably clash, and maybe what
the potential future holds for a
society grappling with such deep
divisions.
And importantly, throughout this
entire discussion, we're going
to remain steadfastly impartial.
We're simply conveying the ideas
and analysis present in our
source material.
Our goal here is purely about
understanding, not taking sides
or endorsing any particular
viewpoint.
Right, just laying out the
concepts as presented.
OK, let's start by really
unpacking that core concept we
introduced.
One man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist.
On the surface, like we said,
it's simple, almost a cliche.
But what does it really mean for
how we perceive the world,
especially through this
framework of dimension A and
dimension B?
Well, it's far more than just
semantics, you know.
It's not just picking different
words for the same action.
Our sources reveal that this
phrase embodies A fundamental
framing device.
A framing device.
Yeah, it's the intrinsic lens
through which individuals
operating within dimension A or
dimension B, Well, they don't
just perceive the world, they
assess actions, assign moral
value, determine legitimacy.
So it dictates how they judge
things.
Precisely.
For those immersed in dimension
A, an act of defiance, no matter
how disruptive it might seem, is
inherently brave.
It's seen as a justified
response to systemic failures.
The whole narrative is 1 of
liberation of challenging
oppressive power structures.
But for those in Dimension B,
that same act is inherently
destructive.
It's an illegitimate challenge
to necessary order.
Their narrative emphasizes the
sanctity of laws, stability,
public safety.
So it's not just describing
reality, you're saying this
perception actually shapes their
reality.
Exactly.
It actively shapes reality
itself.
For those who inhabit either
dimension, it dictates what is
seen as legitimate or
illegitimate, heroic or
villainous, not just as an
opinion, but as a kind of
undeniable truth.
For them, this means that even
the most you know objective
facts can be bent or interpreted
to fit a preexisting moral
framework, which makes finding
common ground incredibly
elusive.
That's a powerful insight,
perception shaping reality,
creating these distinct moral
universes, and it really
reinforces that dimension A and
dimension B aren't just abstract
ideas, there are these deeply
personal psychological
constructs, these deep seated
mental frameworks.
So if you think about it based
on our own individual
experiences, our values, maybe
our upbringing, the media we
consume, even our communities,
how might different people
naturally gravitate towards 1
framework or the other?
What drives this fundamental
split?
Do the sources suggest?
Well, the fact that they're
psychological constructs is
precisely why they're so
profoundly influential and,
frankly, so difficult to shift.
These frameworks fundamentally
dictate how individuals process
incoming information.
Right.
How they make sense of things.
Exactly how they assign meaning
to events, and ultimately how
they form judgments about
identical occurrences.
Think about it this way.
The raw data of an event, say a
protest or an interaction with
law enforcement.
It might be the same for
everyone who sees it.
OK, the objective facts.
Right.
The what happened, but the
narrative constructed around
that data, the interpretation of
motives and tensions, potential
outcomes that will be vastly
different depending on whether
you're viewing it through the
dimension A lens or the
dimension B lens.
Can you give an example?
Sure, someone who has maybe
personally experienced systemic
injustice or belongs to a
marginalized community might
inherently resonate more with
dimension as narrative.
They see defiance as resistance
because that aligns with their
lived experience.
Conversely, someone who
prioritizes societal stability,
perhaps a small business owner
worried about property damage
during a protest, or maybe
someone from a background that
emphasizes strict adherence to
rules, they might naturally
gravitate towards dimension BS.
Emphasis on order and the
necessity of state authority.
OK, and this leads to wildly
divergent conclusions about what
happened, who's at fault, what
the right response should be.
It's like a complete the
ordering of the facts into a
self consistent yet often
contradictory understanding of
the world.
Which is why I guess you often
hear people from opposing sides
expressing genuine disbelief,
right?
Like how can they possibly see
it that way?
Precisely because they're
fundamental reality of the lens
they're using has been shaped
differently.
It almost sounds like you
mentioned parallel universes.
Maybe like 2 parallel trains
running on the same track.
They're moving in the same
general direction, sharing the
same physical space, but they're
operating on entirely separate
rails mentally.
That analogy of parallel trains
is remarkably apartment,
actually.
Yeah.
Our sources pinpoint specific
moments and mechanisms where
these dimensions momentarily and
often frankly, violently
intersect.
OK.
The collision points.
Exactly.
These are primarily viral
videos, social media storms, and
regrettably, real life
conflicts.
And importantly, these aren't
moments of reasoned debate.
You know, where one side tries
to persuade the other with logic
and evidence.
No, it doesn't feel like that
online, does it?
Not at all.
Quite the opposite.
They're typically explosive
clashes of deeply entrenched
pre-existing interpretations.
The incident itself just becomes
the trigger, the spark.
The spark for an immediate,
often unresolvable conflict
between two entirely different
moral narratives.
Take a viral video of an arrest,
for example.
In one dimension it's instantly
seen as police brutality, and
the other it's just as instantly
seen as justified action against
non compliance.
There's rarely an in between.
And the implications of that, I
mean, if two major societal
frameworks exist without true
debate, just these occasional,
often visceral collisions, what
does that mean for trying to
solve problems together?
Well, it suggests A profound
lack of common ground for any
kind of constructive discussion.
It makes genuine societal
consensus increasingly
difficult, maybe even
impossible, to achieve through
conventional political or social
means.
It's a society where factual
truth itself becomes subject to
interpretation, making shared
understanding a really scarce
commodity.
OK, let's really dig into the
role of visual media here.
Our sources highlight how body
Cam footage, dash Cam videos,
those viral clips we just talked
about, how they've become these
incredibly potent mirrors of our
societal divide.
How is it possible for the same
video, the very same set of
images, to be interpreted so
profoundly differently by people
operating in dimension A versus
dimension B?
It really is like watching two
different movies from the same
raw footage.
It's truly one of the most
striking phenomena of our
current information landscape.
When a piece of visual evidence,
say, a police encounter, goes
viral, its interpretation is
almost immediately bifurcated,
split right down the middle.
OK, so in dimension A, these
videos are almost universally
perceived as clear evidence of
vulnerable individuals
courageously standing against
systemic oppression.
The predominant narrative here
is 1, where these individuals
are seen as being crushed by a
heavy-handed state.
Right, the power imbalance
narrative.
Exactly.
It highlights an inherent power
imbalance and a profound sense
of injustice.
The actions of the state, even
if they're procedural or
technically they're the book,
are viewed through a lens of
overreach, excessive force, or
outright oppression.
There's a strong emotional
resonance with the perceived
victim, and the act of defiance
is framed as this desperate,
valiant struggle.
And so the same footage viewed
from dimension B would tell a
completely different story.
What's their narrative?
What did they see in those same
images?
Well, in dimension B, those very
same videos depict individuals
escalating unnecessarily,
refusing lawful orders, and
actively provoking a state
reaction.
OK, so the focus shifts to the
individual's actions.
Entirely for this perspective,
the state's response is then
seen as not only predictable but
also entirely justified, a
necessary measure to maintain
order.
The narrative shifts completely
to one of personal
responsibility, the imperative
of maintaining law and order,
and the legitimate, often
difficult exercise of authority.
There's a focus on the
individuals choices and their
consequences, rather than on the
systemic context that Dimension
A emphasizes.
So the sources emphasize that
the identical factual footage
can lead to two different moral
stories.
Precisely, which dramatically
underscores the profoundly
subjective nature of truth.
In this context, it's less about
what objectively happened and
more about what it means within
one's pre-existing moral and
political framework.
The visual evidence just
confirms what each dimension
already believes about the
world.
OK.
Here's where it gets
particularly interesting, I
think, and it touches on the
incredible power of words
themselves.
Our sources delve into how a
term like authoritarian, a
really loaded word, has
seemingly undergone a radical
transformation in its meaning.
Historically, that word carried
such a negative, even terrifying
weight, right?
It immediately conjured images
of tyranny, oppression,
dictatorships.
Absolutely.
For decades, authoritarian was a
word that instantly invoked a
visceral sense of fear and alarm
across the political spectrum.
It was a potent warning, a stark
signal of oppressive regimes,
basically the opposite of
democracy and freedom.
But now.
But now our sources claim that
in the current climate,
particularly from the
perspective often attributed to
the left, this label has been
applied so broadly, so
liberally.
Well, it now seems to encompass
nearly every display of state
power, even what many might
consider routine law enforcement
actions.
Like what specifically?
We're talking about things like
traffic stops, lawful arrests,
or even the necessary use of
force by police to de escalate a
dangerous situation.
It's as if any exercise of
governmental authority, no
matter the context, is
immediately suspect, immediately
potentially authoritarian.
And what's the profound
consequence of that incredibly
broad application?
I mean, what happens to a
powerful word like that when
almost every single instance of
state power, no matter how minor
or routine, is immediately
branded as fascism or
authoritarianism?
The consequence is incredibly
significant and ironically,
perhaps often self defeating for
those using the term so broadly.
When every display of state
power gets branded with such
extreme labels, the term
authoritarian itself begins to
erode.
It loses its specific historical
meaning, It's critical
precision, exactly it's
impactful warning power.
It transforms from a precise
description of a political
system into a generalized,
almost casual accusation rather
than a tool for nuanced
analysis.
So, thinking bigger picture,
what happens when critical terms
lose their precision in public
discourse?
When they just become
generalized accusations.
Well, meaningful dialogue
becomes almost impossible,
doesn't it?
The words lose their ability to
convey specific, important
concepts.
If everything is fascism, then
nothing truly is, and we lose
the ability to identify genuine
threats when they might actually
appear.
It makes it difficult to even
agree on what we're discussing,
let alone debate its merits.
This kind of linguistic
inflation just numbs the public
to the true meaning of the word.
This then raises a truly
provocative and frankly almost
absurd question.
Given its historical baggage,
how could authoritarianism
possibly for any group, become a
compliment or even a desired
trait?
It seems completely
counterintuitive.
It does.
But our sources present a
fascinating and, yeah, somewhat
chilling argument for this
semantic shift.
They contend that for a
significant segment of
Americans, particularly those
who are deeply concerned about
what they see as the erosion of
order and stability,
authoritarianism begins to
simply mean authority.
Authority getting things done.
Basically, it's remarkable
redefinition born out of a
perceived societal void, when
authority is seen as the
necessary force that holds back
chaos, keeps contracts
enforceable, and makes
neighborhoods livable.
You know, when it's viewed as
the essential backbone of a
functioning society?
Then, for those who value order
and stability above all else,
the ladle transforms.
It shifts from being an insult,
a term of condemnation, into a
positive descriptor, maybe even
a compliment for someone who
effectively takes charge and re
establishes control.
Wow.
So the implication there is
profound.
It really is.
It means groups who historically
would have reacted with alarm to
the term authoritarianism might
now do to this redefinition, and
perhaps their desperate craving
for stability, view certain
strong, decisive displays of
state power as desirable, even
necessary, rather than
tyrannical.
It completely flips the script
on how different groups perceive
state power, and it's legitimate
exercise.
Exactly.
And it highlights a growing
desperation for order that
might, for some, override
traditional democratic
principles.
OK, let's shift our focus now to
what our sources call the
freedom fighter archetype.
When you hear that term freedom
fighter, what images typically
come to mind?
Maybe, I don't know, a
historical revolutionary like
George Washington or a figure
fighting against a colonial
power, something like that.
Yeah, those are the classic
examples, the romanticized
figures.
But our sources describe a
significant and pretty
consequential modern expansion
of this idea, particularly
within dimension A How has the
very definition of a freedom
fighter broadened in
contemporary discourse,
according to them?
Well, our sources contend that
what they refer to as the left
has dramatically broadened the
idea of a freedom fighter to
include, and this is a direct
quote, nearly anyone who defies
the state.
Nearly anyone who defies the
state.
That's incredibly broad.
It's a massive expansion from
the traditional understanding.
Like you said, Historically a
freedom fighter might have been
someone risking their life
against a foreign occupation or
an oppressive dictatorship.
Now, this label is apparently
applied to a much wider array of
individuals and groups, often
those engaged in forms of civil
disobedience or direct action
that might not typically be
associated with classic freedom
movements.
Why?
What's the underlying thinking
there?
The underlying premise seems to
be that the state itself or its
institutions are seen as
fundamentally oppressive.
Therefore, any defiance becomes
a form of liberation.
Can you give us some specific
examples from the source
material?
Who exactly falls under this
expanded umbrella of freedom
fighter in dimension A, and what
does this broadening really
signify?
Certainly, the sources provide
quite a range Activists,
rioters, Antifa militants, white
suburban women screaming at
police and St. crews shutting
down intersections in the name
of fun.
Wow, that's a very diverse group
from activists to St. crews
blocking traffic for fun.
It is, and they're all presented
as figures who, within dimension
A, are elevated as symbols of
resistance.
So what are the potential
reasons, strategically or
ideologically, for such a broad
expansion of the freedom fighter
label?
Well, it could be seen as an
attempt to legitimize a much
wider range of confrontational
actions against the state by
framing them all within this
narrative of heroic defiance and
the pursuit of social justice.
Well, it imbues their actions
with the kind of moral
righteousness, regardless of the
methods used.
So it cast them as heroes.
It cast them as heroes in an
ongoing struggle against an
inherently unjust system.
This cast a very wide net,
making almost any form of
opposition to state authority a
form of noble resistance, even
if those actions cause
disruption or significant
discomfort for others.
It seems to be about creating a
unified narrative of resistance,
where all acts of defiance are
connected by a shared moral
imperative.
OK, so if Dimension A perceives
these individuals and groups as
freedom fighters, heroic
resistors against an oppressive
system, how does Dimension B
perceive them?
What's the Stark counter
narrative?
What do they call these very
same figures?
Well, according to the sources
to the populist nationalist
right and the majority who value
order, these very same figures
are unequivocally labeled as the
terrorists of Dimension B.
Terrorists.
That's a strong word.
It is.
They're not seen as heroes at
all, but as agents of chaos who
actively undermine stability,
destroy property, threaten
public safety and disrespect the
rule of law.
So.
It's a complete inversion.
A complete inversion.
The sources highlight the stark,
irreconcilable contrast in
perception.
One side calls it bravery, the
other calls it madness.
This fundamental disagreement on
the characterization of these
individuals and their actions is
absolute.
It leaves basically no room for
negotiation or common ground.
It's a foundational worldview
clash.
And you can see this clash of
archetypes playing out
constantly, right in public
debates, policy discussions,
cultural narratives.
Oh, absolutely.
One news outlet might lionize A
protest leader, highlighting
their cause and courage, while
another condemns them as a
dangerous radical, focusing
entirely on their disruptive
methods.
And in policy?
In policy debates, it means one
side might advocate for, say,
police reform and de escalation
techniques, viewing the
encounters through Dimension A's
lens, while the other side
demands stricter enforcement,
harsher penalties, seeing the
same events through Dimension
B's lens as criminal behavior
needing suppression.
It makes productive discourse
incredibly difficult.
Because the foundational
understanding of the actors
involved is so diametrically
opposed, it's a clash not just
of opinions but a fundamental
world views, each utterly
convinced of its own moral
superiority and the depravity,
or least the dangerous folly, of
the other.
So what does this deeply divided
landscape, these colliding
realities, what does it
ultimately mean for the future
of a society facing such
prolonged internal conflict?
History often gives us clues,
doesn't it, about where things
might be headed when you have
such deeply entrenched, mutually
exclusive realities coexisting?
History, as our sources keenly
observe, suggest a very specific
and often uncomfortable pattern.
Every prolonged conflict,
whether it's internal or
external, eventually seems to
reach what is termed A tipping
point.
A tipping point?
OK, what does that mean exactly?
It's not just a gradual shift.
It's usually an event, or maybe
a series of events that is so
jarring, so disruptive, so
unequivocally significant that
it compels everyone within that
society to choose a side.
It forces a choice, ends the
ambiguity.
Exactly.
It effectively ends.
Neutrality dissolves all's
ambiguity, enforces a definitive
alignment.
The psychological and societal
pressure that such a moment
exerts is immense.
It makes fence sitting or
remaining detached simply
untenable.
The luxury of ambivalence
disappears.
It's stripped away.
Individuals are forced to
confront which fundamental
reality, Dimension A or
dimension B they truly inhabit
and ultimately wish to uphold.
It's a moment of brutal clarity
where previous allegiances or
sympathies might be severely
tested, may be reevaluated in
the face of an undeniable
crisis.
And our sources provide a
powerful, very recent example of
precisely this kind of tipping
point, the events of October 7th
in Israel.
How does that serve as an
illustration of this concept?
Indeed, the events of October
7th serve as a chilling and
potent example of exactly this
kind of societal tipping point,
not just within Israel but
globally, in terms of how it
fractured perceptions almost
instantly.
The sources state unequivocally
that one side immediately saw
resistance, viewing the actions
of the lens of Dimension A as a
fight against occupation, A
struggle for liberation, however
violent the mean.
In stark contrast, the other
side unequivocally saw terrorism
requiring eradication, viewing
the same actions through the
lens of Dimension B as an
abhorrent, unprovoked attack on
civilians demanding a swift and
absolute response.
So an immediate non negotiable
divide.
Immediate, visceral, non
negotiable.
It left virtually no room for
nuanced interpretation or middle
ground.
The event instantly bifurcated
global opinion, forcing
individuals and nations alike
into a clear alignment with one
narrative or the other.
It really demonstrated how a
single catastrophic event can
expose and solidify pre-existing
ideological divides.
The raw horror of the events
just made neutrality impossible
for many, demanding A moral
stance that then dictated their
entire interpretation going
forward.
This then leads us to a very
stark and maybe unsettling
question for us here in the
United States.
Given the deep internal
divisions we've been discussing,
could America face its own
version of such a moment?
And if so, what might be the
potential catalysts?
What could push us to that
tipping point?
Well, the sources delve into
potential catalysts for
America's own tipping point, and
they paint a pretty sobering
picture of possibilities,
scenarios that could shatter the
fragile coexistence of
dimensions.
A&B like what?
They suggest Things such as a
coordinated riot wave implying
widespread synchronized civil
unrest across multiple locations
simultaneously.
OK, mass unrest.
Or a domestic terror act of
significant scale, perhaps
targeting critical
infrastructure or a large
population center.
Or maybe a mass breakdown of
public order that leaves
communities feeling abandoned,
unprotected by established
authority.
These aren't just abstract
fields 10, but specific
potential triggers.
According to our sources, yes,
specific triggers that could
force a national reckoning.
And the prediction is stark.
When this moment arrives, it
will not leave the country
unchanged.
It won't be a return to business
as usual back.
Instead, it will force a
fundamental, maybe existential,
choice upon the nation, a
decision that will define its
future trajectory.
And the implication the choice
presented, it sounds dire.
It is profoundly serious.
The sources present 2 dire,
almost apocalyptic sounding
options.
Will Americans, faced with
overwhelming chaos, demand a
harsh crackdown, a decisive,
perhaps severe reassertion of
order that prioritizes stability
above all else, potentially at
the cost of certain liberties?
Or will the nation spiral
towards civil war, a complete
and catastrophic breakdown of
societal cohesion, with the
divides become utterly
irreconcilable and potentially
violent?
The weight and finality of such
a choice as presented by the
sources are immense and, they
suggest, perhaps unavoidable.
It beats a picture of an
inevitable confrontation with
core societal values.
Let's now delve into a truly
critical and exceptionally
sensitive issue that complicates
enforcement in this fractured
societal landscape.
What are sources refer to as the
racial optics problem?
Even if laws are applied
absolutely fairly with no bias,
what does the source material
say about how enforcement
actions are perceived,
especially in the context of
these two dimensions we've been
discussing?
This is an incredibly complex
and, yeah, emotionally charged
issue.
It poses a significant challenge
to any kind of authority trying
to maintain order.
The sources explained that even
if enforcement is evenly applied
across all demographics, the
object of that enforcement will
almost always be racialized.
Always be racialized, even if
fair.
How?
It isn't necessarily about the
intent behind the enforcement
action itself, but rather it's
visual interpretation,
particularly when these moments
are captured on camera and go
viral.
The viral videos again.
Exactly those prime collision
points for Dimensions A&B.
Viral images, the sources argue,
will disproportionately focus on
black suspects.
It's just the nature of what
gets shared and amplified.
And as a result, the narrative
that swiftly emerges, especially
within Dimension A, will then
inevitably frame any crackdown,
any reassertion of state
authority, as a return to
America's darkest chapters.
It evokes powerful historical
injustices.
Jim Crow the civil rights era
struggles.
The perception, regardless of
the factual impartiality, of
this specific incident becomes 1
of systemic oppression targeting
specific communities.
And how does this racial optics
problem impact the ability of
the state, particularly law
enforcement, to act decisively?
Does it create a kind of
paralysis where legitimate
actions are held back simply by
the fear of how they will be
perceived?
Absolutely.
The sources describe this
phenomenon Is creating a
powerful shield.
Shield.
Yes, this shield makes decisive
enforcement politically
untouchable.
The immense fear among
politicians, among agency heads,
of being accused of racism, of
being seen as perpetuating
historical oppression,
effectively paralyzes state
action, even when there might be
a clear, urgent need for
intervention to restore public
order or safety.
So it creates this challenging
paradox.
It does.
The very groups perhaps calling
for justice and accountability
may inadvertently hamstring the
state's ability to act when
necessary.
Because of this fear of the
optics, the profound complexity
lies in addressing real societal
issues.
When the optics are so easily
manipulated or misinterpreted,
regardless of the underlying
intent, it creates an
environment where legitimate
actions, however necessary they
might seem to mention B, can be
delegitimized simply by their
visual presentation and how they
slot into the pre-existing,
deeply ingrained narratives of
dimension A.
And this paralysis means that
problems can just fester,
disorder can grow.
Because the political cost of
strong action is perceived as
just too high.
But can this shield, this
political paralysis born of
optics, Can it last
indefinitely?
Does our source material suggest
there's a limit to its power, a
point where other factors might
override these concerns?
The.
Sources directly address this.
They stay quite pointedly.
But Shields can break.
There's a fundamental breaking
point, a critical threshold
where the dynamics fundamentally
shift, where the fear of
negative optics becomes
secondary to a more primal
concern.
This occurs, according to the
sources, when ordinary people
feel cornered and endangered and
endangered.
They care less about accusations
and more about survival.
This marks a profound
instinctual shift in societal
priorities.
It's not intellectual anymore.
It's gut level.
And that shift?
The sources emphasize that shift
changes everything.
The implication here is
critical.
Consider the societal
consequences when the Basic
Instinct for survival, for self
preservation, overrides
political correctness, overrides
accusations of systemic bias or
even perceived injustice.
When personal safety, the
security of your family, the
stability of your community are
genuinely felt to be at stake,
the priorities of a significant
portion of the population shift
dramatically.
Which could lead to.
What it could lead to a
widespread acceptance of, or
even a demand for actions that
might otherwise be condemned as
overly harsh or discriminatory.
It's a stark warning that basic
human needs for security can
eventually override more complex
social and political concerns.
This then leads us to another
potent historical pattern that
our sources highlight.
What happens when the state may
be paralyzed by the shield or
other factors, hesitates or
fails to act decisively in the
face of escalating disorder?
What fills that vacuum?
History, as the sources
emphatically point out, provides
a very clear and often
unsettling answer.
When the state hesitates to
enforce its own laws, private
citizens fill the vacuum.
Vigilantism.
Essentially, yes.
This isn't just a theoretical
concept, it's a recurring
societal phenomena.
The sources cite the vigilante
wave of the 1970s in America,
for instance.
They frame it as a direct
historical reflection of a deep
distrust of government and an
appetite for self-defense among
the populace.
During a period of perceived
disorder and rising crime rates,
citizens feeling abandoned or
unprotected by the state took
matters into their own hands.
Fast forward to today, and the
risk of this phenomenon
recurring is, the sources argue,
exponentially greater.
They explicitly state today,
with half a billion privately
owned guns, that risk is even
greater.
Half a billion.
That statistic alone underscores
the sheer scale of potential
private action.
And the inherent danger when
individual citizens feel
compelled to take on roles
traditionally reserved for the
state.
And what are the specific
actions, according to the
sources, that actively
contribute to this weakening of
state authority, things that
might pave the way for private
citizens to step in and fill
that perceived vacuum?
The sources are quite explicit
on this.
They named several actions that
they argue contribute to this
dangerous erosion of state
authority.
Things like defunding police,
which obviously reduces law
enforcement presence and
capacity, right?
Then there's suing officers into
paralysis, creating an
environment where officers fear
career ending legal
repercussions even for
legitimate actions, which
naturally leads to hesitation.
The deep policing idea.
Exactly.
And finally, labeling
enforcement as fascism, which,
as we discussed earlier,
delegitimizes the very concept
of state authority in the eyes
of many, particularly in
Dimension B.
So.
These actions regardless of
intent.
Regardless of their intended
motivations or goals, they are
presented by the sources as
actively weakening the state's
capacity and willingness to
maintain order.
But, and this is crucial, the
sources make a very important
distinction.
While these actions may indeed
weaken state authority, they
cannot erase the citizens
instinct to protect their own.
That fundamental drive.
That fundamental human drive for
self preservation, for the
safety of 1's family and
property, remains incredibly
powerful, unyielding.
It's a force that cannot simply
be legislated or protested away.
And the warning from the sources
if that instinct takes over.
The warning is stark and
unmeasured.
If Americans decide they must
act unilaterally, the
consequences will not be
measured or polite.
This suggests the potential for
uncontrolled escalation,
widespread violence driven by a
desperate, raw need for
perceived order and security,
operating entirely outside of,
or perhaps even in direct
opposition to state control.
It's a vision of a potentially
chaotic self help society
emerging from the breakdown of
state authority.
OK, let's turn our attention now
to a group that often gets
overlooked in the daily noise of
public discourse, yet hold
immense potential power
according to our sources, the
silent majority.
Who are they truly, and what are
their fundamental beliefs that
make them so impactful when they
finally decide to act?
Right.
The silent majority.
Our sources define them as the
patient ones who keep to
themselves.
These aren't the ideologues, not
the activists, not the vocal
proponents hammering away for
either Dimension A or Dimension
B online or in protests.
Just regular people.
Largely yes.
Individuals who by their nature
tend to be less vocal in public
debates, less engaged in
ideological arguments.
They're more focused on their
daily lives, their families,
their jobs, their communities.
They are characterized as having
a practical sort of non academic
view of the world, prioritizing
stability over abstract ideals
and.
Their core belief, What drives
them?
Their core belief, the
fundamental operating principle
that underpins their entire
worldview, is described as
remarkably simple and pragmatic.
They believe law and order make
peace and peace makes life
possible.
Order equals peace equals life.
Simple.
For them, this isn't a political
slogan or an ideological stance.
It's presented as a fundamental
truth upon which their ability
to live their lives, raise their
children, build their futures
depends entirely.
And their power lies where if
they're silent.
The often underestimated power
of this group lies precisely in
their quiet pragmatism and their
sheer numbers.
While they're not constantly in
the headlines, their collective
will, when it's finally roused
by a perceived threat to these
foundational values, can be a
potent, potentially overwhelming
force for change, precisely
because their values, basic
safety predictability, are so
fundamental and broadly held by
average citizens.
And what happens when this
silent majority is pushed too
far, When their fundamental
belief in peace through order is
genuinely threatened?
Our sources suggest their
response isn't necessarily
proportional.
Is it when they feel truly
cornered?
That's a crucial and often
overlooked insight from the
sources.
Yes, they state that when
cornered, they do not respond
proportionally.
They overcorrect.
Overcorrect.
What does that mean in practice?
Well, overcorrect implies a
response that isn't merely
reactive or balanced.
It goes significantly beyond
what might be considered a
measured incremental reaction.
Think of a pendulum swinging
hard the other way.
So not just fixing the problem,
but maybe going much further.
Potentially, in practical terms,
it could mean supporting
policies, leaders or actions
that are far more assertive,
maybe even punitive, than what
they might typically endorse
during times of relative calm.
They're not seeking reform or
nuanced solutions.
At that point, the sources
suggest, they are seeking the
swift re establishment of the
fundamental peace and order they
believe is essential for life to
be possible.
Their patients, once exhausted,
gives way to a demand for
decisive, often uncompromising
action.
They might become willing to
sacrifice certain liberties or
procedural niceties for the sake
of restoring stability.
There's a particularly crucial
irony here that the sources
identify, one that suggests A
profound, perhaps unintended,
consequence of the strategy
employed by some, specifically
the left as described in the
sources.
How has consistently labeling
every exercise of authority as
fascism potentially backfired in
such a significant way?
This is perhaps one of the most
sobering and, yeah,
strategically ironic
observations presented in the
sources.
They argue that the left, by
branding every exercise of
authority is fascism, is
inadvertently teaching Americans
to associate authoritarianism
with someone finally doing
something.
Wow.
Say that again, they're teaching
people to associate
authoritarianism with getting
things done.
That's the argument.
It's a profound and, as you
noted, deeply unintended
consequence.
By consistently applying the
most extreme, historically
loaded label to even routine
displays of governmental
authority, from a traffic stop
to enforcing a municipal
ordinance, the term itself
becomes desensitized.
It gets redefined in the public
consciousness.
And the critical implication of
that.
The critical implication is that
this desensitization and
redefinition could perversely
pave the way for actions that
would typically be rejected,
maybe even feared, by a
democratic populace, if
authoritarianism becomes
synonymous with effective
action, action that curbs chaos,
restores order, makes
neighborhoods feel safe again.
Then people might actually want
it.
Then those desperate for
stability and peace might,
paradoxically, not only tolerate
it, but actively embrace it.
They might see a strong leader,
someone willing to act
decisively as the only one
willing to do something, rather
than as a threat to their
liberties, precisely because the
extreme label fascism or
authoritarian, has lost its
original terror through overuse.
So what was intended as a
warning against tyranny could,
for a significant portion of the
population, become a welcome
sign of strength because they're
just tired of the chaos.
That's the danger highlighted by
the sources, yes.
This chilling irony then brings
us to the ultimate conclusion
presented by the sources.
When this inevitable backlash
from the silent majority comes
fueled by this dynamic, what
will it look like?
What's its fundamental nature
and what distinguishes it from,
say, a typical reform movement?
The sources prediction here is
stark and uncompromising.
It leaves very little room for
ambiguity.
They emphasize that when the
backlash comes, it will not look
like reform.
No.
This isn't about incremental
changes or polite adjustments to
the system, or a careful
recalibration of policies.
It won't be driven by a desire
for nuanced improvement or
societal introspection.
What drives it then?
Instead, it'll be driven by a
primal, non negotiable need for
fundamental survival and the
restoration of a basic operating
environment.
The sources final chilling
statement encapsulates this
perfectly, and it resonates with
the kind of raw, undeniable
force they will look like.
Survival survive, and survival
never asks permission.
Wow, survival never asks
permission.
It highlights the unmeasured,
potentially brutal and
unconstrained nature of such a
societal response.
It implies actions that might
disregard established norms,
legal niceties, perhaps even
democratic processes, all in
service of what is perceived as
an absolute necessity.
Restore order.
Ensure security.
It's a vision of a society
pushed past its breaking point,
where the most fundamental human
instincts override all other
considerations.
We've covered a remarkable
amount of ground today,
navigating the complex, often
turbulent landscape of America's
two realities.
We've explored the fundamental
clash of dimension A and
dimension B, how critical terms
like authoritarianism have
drastically shifted their
meaning, the potential for a
societal tipping point that
could redefine our nation, and
the profound, often overlooked
consequences of neglecting the
deep seated human instinct for
order and self preservation.
It's clear that these forces are
incredibly complex, deeply
intertwine, and constantly
shaping the American landscape.
Often, you know, beneath the
surface of the Daily News
cycles.
And understanding these two
realities, even if you find
yourself strongly aligning with
one particular dimension, one
way of seeing things, is
absolutely crucial for anyone
seeking to comprehend the
current societal tensions.
And maybe the potential
trajectory of the country.
It's not about choosing a side
or endorsing 1 viewpoint over
another.
It's really about truly grasping
the motivations, the fears, and
the fundamental perceptions of
those inhabiting a different
dimension.
To see the whole picture, to
understand why others see the
world so differently, even when
confronted with the same facts.
That's the essential first step
toward any meaningful
understanding of our current
moment and what might lie ahead.
It's about developing a kind of
intellectual empathy, maybe to
see the world not just as you
perceive it, but as others
genuinely experience it.
Absolutely.
That's well put.
So as we wrap up this deep dive,
here's a final thought for you,
our listener, to Mull over.
Building on everything we've
unpacked today, considering
everything, we've discussed the
subjective nature of truth, the
redefinition of core concepts,
and that primal drive for order.
What might be the single most
defining characteristic of true
order in a society where so many
see chaos and resistance so
differently?
And maybe more personally, what
might each of us, regardless of
our dimension, truly be willing
to sacrifice for it?
That's a heavy one to end on.
It is something to think about.
Thank you for joining us on this
exploration of the profound
truths shaping our world.
We encourage you to continue
exploring these complex ideas
and observing how they play out
in the world around you, maybe
through the lens of these two
colliding realities.